protestors in Baghdad spent a second day
confronting security forces as they
attempted to breach this barrier their
aim was to march across a bridge to
government offices in the fortified
green zone protesters have been in
Tahrir Square around-the-clock since
Thursday evening they say some have been
attacked without provocation in the
early morning hours while journalists
aren't around we want to make sure
that's we will just demonstrate in a
safe way as we won't that we won't get
killed I don't want to die today I want
to have a good country about 200 Iraqis
have been killed since the latest
anti-government protests began at the
beginning of this month people are angry
about the lack of jobs corruption
discrimination and the cost of living
prime minister Adel Abdul Mahadi has
promised various reforms but he's
refusing to meet the protesters main
demand that he resigns along with his
government he says that would create
chaos there sitting on their couches and
they're shooting us what do they think
we are chickens they're spraying tear
gas on us do we need more tears or
martyrs either die or topple the
government the Ministry of Interior
released a statement on Saturday
condemning the people it says attacked
security forces and vandalized
government and political party buildings
a spokesman says they did not use
excessive force and they're committed to
protecting the human rights of peaceful
protesters amid the stun grenades and
tear gas we met I met Don hoon and his
two-year-old son 18 years I work with
the Ministry of Interior and my reward
was being fired I have been protesting
here and trying to get another contract
for four months every day they give us
promises to calm us and say tomorrow and
nothing Abbas who dare says he's
protesting for the chance his four
children might have a future
he once hoped for 2003 I have good and
real life a simple life
and happy life after 2003 I lose my job
my family destroyed my future destroyed
members of parliament were due to meet
on Saturday but the session was
cancelled because not enough of them
turned up with the country in crisis
protestors see that as yet another
example of a government death to their
demands
Natasha guy named Al Jazeera Baghdad